freak journal talks about John Paulson
whose hedge fund made twenty billion
dollars by betting against the housing
market in 2007 and 2008 MIT Sloan School
of Management Cambridge Massachusetts
hosts the 50 minute event thanks very
much I appreciate the opportunity to
come speak about my book a passion of
mine it's my baby and I love discussing
it and I still find it interesting so I
hope you guys do too so I'm going to
talk a little bit about patience some
lessons from the research behind my book
and I'll also talk a little bit about
what's going on now on Wall Street and
some of the big traders and that I cover
day to day what they're betting on what
they're bidding against and I'll leave
some time for a QA I often find in these
kind of settings people have an interest
in discussing journalism financial
journalism per se
perhaps Wall Street Journal and what
we're focused on those kinds of things
so feel free to kind of ask about the
book or any of those kinds of questions
as well my book is called the grip it's
about the winners in the whole crisis
and just taking a step back I'll tell
you a little bit about myself and sort
of how I found this project I've been at
the Wall Street Journal about 13 years
and I've covered different things the
bond market and the hurt on the street
column I've written and write about
hedge funds and I've been always been
very interested in fascinated by big
trades and strikeouts and big home runs
as it were on Wall Street I guess it's
my um I'm a sports guy so I like big
strikeouts and homeruns and I also feel
as a writer there's a lot of drama in in
lessons to be learned from people that
make really good decisions and do really
well as well as those kind of make
mistakes and you can learn from those as
well so those always have the most drama
and the most interest to me so here I
was in the fall of 2007 sitting at my
desk
things were starting to get bad Wall
Street firms were losing lots of money
Merrill Lynch City and I was covering
some of the stuff a lot of my colleagues
and kind of figuring out who's next to
fall and who's going to have more
problems and eventually things got much
worse obviously and I got a call from a
big hedge fund manager and this is sort
of what I do we trade information and he
said Greg I just play tennis with a guy
his name is John Paulson I barely knew
who he was at the time this is the hedge
fund manager saying it and I just could
not believe how much money he's making
now while everyone else is losing money
and it was intriguing a conversation
both because here was a guy who's
actually doing well as the world was
starting to implode but also because my
contact who was among the the biggest
hedge fund managers out there on Wall
Street and most respected investor he
hardly knew much about this guy John
Paulson so if he didn't know much about
him and I had heard of John Paulson and
I met with him a few times but he wasn't
exactly on my radar screen at the time
so he didn't know much about I might
know that much about I mean yet he was
the one which figured this whole thing
out so they got me really excited so I
started working on this project I wrote
a front-page story for The Wall Street
Journal then I followed it up with a
about a year or so of work on my book in
my book is about it's about the winners
in this crisis as I said john paulson
and others but behind it all what
propels it all is sort of a conundrum
that it shouldn't have been john paulson
it shouldn't have been these investors
that i write about who made the billions
and figured it out and anticipated this
collapse the investors who should have
been the ones I was writing about
included people like George Soros
obviously been against the British Pound
at the time it had been the greatest
trade ever until john paulson and the
investors that I write about he he
should have done this trade he didn't
warren buffett obviously you know the
greatest investor of our waar of the
century of a past century or so he
could have done it he didn't do it Mike
vrai knows is a expert in
mortgage-backed securities and that's
what John Paulson threw himself into
learning about and analyzing and betting
against and my brightest into this trade
Jim Chanos is the most famous short
seller out there and this trade is a
short sale is betting against things and
Jim Chanos didn't do this trade David
Tepper who is someone I wrote about more
recently he made seven billion dollars
last year and he's he's known for his
big trades big bets isn't care if things
go up go down he's okay with that it's
very volatile he didn't do this trade he
was told about this trade he friends of
his and some including some of the
people that I write about said hey you
need to be doing this trade and he
didn't and that kind of fascinates me
and continues to do so and yet so wasn't
these group of kind of the big names on
Wall Street and those that did it
include john paulson as i mentioned and
just to tell you a little bit about john
paulson he spent a year oh I'm sorry
spent a career on Wall Street he went to
NYU undergraduate very well went to
Harvard Business School again did well
and start off as an investment banker
Bear Stearns and then he left to do his
own investing as his own hedge fund but
what he focused on when he specialized
in was merger arbitrage and merger
arbitrage is among the safest kinds of
investing basically you buy the stock
that's being acquired and you short bet
against the company that's doing the
acquisition and you know you could shake
it up a little bit and sometimes he did
but it's not full of risk you can do
better than the next guy and john
paulson had a good career and had a good
track record but it was a merger RB
never did more than you know 15 20
percent gains in a single year and yet
he was the one who did his trade his
right-hand man the one really key in his
trade is a gentleman named paulo
Pellegrini and paolo is a native of
italy and also a smart graduate of
Harvard Business School he is even more
unlikely to have played such a crucial
all in the greatest financial coup in
history he spent a career kicking around
Wall Street he was an investment banker
at Lazard frères into very well
never got a promotion that he nettie
always wanted never really rose very far
ends up leaving Lazard frères I'm
trading on his own he didn't do so well
he he traded tried traders is one of his
head it was twice divorce and traded
some of his wife's money a little bit
didn't really work out so well it had
some he's great ideas yeah you don't
wanna do that too much
he hit his great ideas always had great
business idea it was an innovative guy
but didn't really work out so well for
him again sharp as they come and yet so
he calls up in the spring of 2005 he was
out of a job he was living in
Westchester north of New York City in a
one-bedroom apartment he had two
children from his marriages when I was
two marriages and he didn't have to go
back to Italy and leave them behind his
children so he really wanted a job and
he was approaching 50 and it's tough on
Wall Street it's a young person's kind
of business the financial industry and
he was aware that he called up John
Paulson asking for a job and they
overlapped a little bit at Bear Stearns
and Paulson took his call and this again
is 2005 and Paulson said well the only
job I really have here Palo is as an
analyst and it's only because somebody
is left to go to business school so
you'd only want that job a lot of grunt
work and Paula said no no I'll take that
job I'd like that job and he ended up
joining Paulson company and again
unlikely two years later in the fall of
2007 he was on vacation with his his new
his third wife and talk about talking
about the greatest trade ever
so he's on vacation with his new wife
and they're in the st. Barts and they
stopped to check the ATM sheets she
stops to just get some money out of the
ATM and he hadn't really told his wife
too much about the trade they were
working on
they he's a little superstitious and he
didn't want to jinx it too much and she
had a vague awareness that was going
pretty well but not not many details she
didn't give him too many details and so
she's at the ATM and she said since
she's like Paulo there's 45 million
dollars in her account and to that time
he really had very little money in his
bank account which is kind of shocking
that 45 million dollars was part of the
175 million dollars that he made as a
bonus for that trade for that year 2007
s trade so again he goes from having
nothing really in a one-bedroom
apartment in 2005 to two years later
he's got 175 million dollars in the bank
and in st. Barts having a good time so
he's again he's unlikely hobbies at Pala
Pellegrini the other characters I track
equally unlikely there's a doctor turned
investor he's in Northern California
named Michael burry and Michael burry
actually was early on his trade before
Paulson before many others and he's a
headstrong guy's a little bit stubborn
he didn't always get along so well with
his own investors a lot of them didn't
really believe in him he was a doctor
and he was doing really well with
betting on stocks but this this and as
we'll talk about in a second his trade
and nothing really doeth stocks
it was derivatives it was mortgages and
as a lot of his own invested ear only
believed in him and they were skeptical
and burry kind of persisted and he gets
a lot of credit and he's really both a
kind guy and a generous guy but he can
be a little stubborn and again unlikely
and an interesting guy to me have pulled
us off in Southern California another
gentleman I write about Jeffrey Greene
who was sort of this kind of cliched
Hollywood type he was a real estate
investor who made a lot and then lost it
all
and had made it more afterwards and he
basically steals the idea from John
Paulson
and it runs with it and they were good
friends and he did a lot of his own work
though he gets a lot of credit as well
and again he's not kind of the obvious
guy to pulled off the greatest trade in
financial history there's a young guy
Andrew Andrew Lodi in Santa Monica
California who looks more like a surfer
than an investor and he's very
passionate about his investing the whole
thing is really as passionate about is
legalizing marijuana so again you can
talk about both he can really get off
and go off on both of them so again the
guy you really wouldn't predict and
there's a guy named Greg Lippmann who's
a trader at Deutsche Bank and still is
as of right now there's kind of rumors
that he might leave but he basically is
told by colleagues around him that
housing is going to hold up and he
ignores them and he really risks his
career to bet against housing in bet
against subprime mortgages and to pull
this trade off so in my view these guys
are all sort of the climbing up a
mountain and they're going to the top
and Paulson makes it to the top and a
few others come close but not all do
some slide back down and why some
succeed and why some didn't is a
fascination of mine and that's sort of
why I wrote the book and why was these
guys and not the the expert so-called
experts so that sort of kind of drives
the book as well as the dynamic of
writing about winners I thought it would
be more enjoyable to write about and to
read about the individuals who figure
this out and we can learn from these
people as well I think as opposed to
those who made the mistakes so that's
another reason why kind of I threw
myself into this book in this in this
project and I still find it kind of
fascinating the first thing I wanted to
kind of discuss is why the experts
didn't see it and that kind of runs
through my whole book because it's a
fascinating period of time in our in our
financial system in our nation as
history because the very people that
created this toxic kind of mortgage and
toxic investments all these kind of
things that blew up
this dreck were the very people that got
burned the most by them and there's sort
of this kind of view now that those
investment cars were sort of evil in or
out to to get the investors and I don't
think that's the case and the proof
being that they got hurt the most if you
think about a citigroup and merrill
lynch and a lot of other of the major
names the holidays of Wall Street the
investment banks are the very ones who
created this stuff so in other words
it's like almost like a butcher who has
this this poisonous meat and knows it's
poisonous or maybe should know it's
poisonous I guess that's the point
brings it home instead of selling it all
brings it home and serves it to the kids
and it's always been a fascinating thing
to me and why that's the case and
because again there's this sort of
understanding that well they knew what
they were doing and make einde of choice
it on investors and they really did it I
mean I know I know some of these people
there's a gentleman in my community in
my little town in New Jersey and he
created he worked at Lehman Brothers and
he created some of the CDO stuff so I
talked to these people that's sort of
what I do and I've got sort of some
observations as a were to try to answer
that question because oh I've always
been curious about it and some of them
are kind of more obvious than others I
think I mean if you think about it
there's been an evolution there's maybe
there always has been Andrew and smell
is probably more experts than I but
there's an evolution it was an evolution
in the creation of some of these
investment products and first I had
mortgages and then he had more exact
securities and then they evolved to well
let's take some those mortgage-backed
securities and then put them with some
other debt product and create these CDOs
credit default obligations and then
you've got most synthetic versions and
then credit default swaps and things
really evolved and became much more
complicated each year and everyone kind
of try to outdo the next in terms of
creating these products and to me it got
to the point where the very people at
the investment banks didn't really
understand them where they should have
and what happened was in my view you had
sort of two tiers you had the senior
people now the senior people the Robert
Rubin some of the world and the Chuck
princes
and Stan O'Neill's who say no ran
Maryland the first two gentlemen helped
run Citigroup and they were just too
senior and they really didn't know what
many of these products were or their
risk and they deferred to the people
below them and you can criticize them
for that but they deferred both to the
people below them who were the experts
as well as the models that that everyone
was relying on and these models were
based on historic data and a lot of that
was based on just the fact of housing
never in our country had ever fallen on
a national level at least more than a
you know small blip of a month or two if
that and so the models all kind of said
well the stuff is safe relatively safe
and the rating agencies all said it's
safe so it was a little bit of a passing
the buck and it was a little bit of well
I can't really understand it myself so
I'm going to defer to these experts and
the experts were either relying on
models or they were focused on their
competition and on Wall Street
unfortunately we're at the point where
everyone is worried about the next guy
and everyone's worried about the next
quarter and meeting earnings so my
friend in in my town he's not a bad guy
he just knew that if he wasn't creating
this CDO even if it was toxic somebody
else would be and I don't think also he
thought they were so bad they got caught
up in it and it's fascinating the bigger
these firms got the more each group it's
in I've talked a lot of these people
each group knew about their own area and
the risk level and maybe they said well
yeah I can see what bad could happen but
they didn't have a general larger view
of how could affect other groups how the
dominoes could fall and the overall risk
of the firm there were some firms that
were better than others Goldman Sachs
does a much better job of drilling down
and seeing where the risk is throughout
its old system that said goldman sachs
was laid at catching this as well they
get a lot of credit and people either
love them or hate them but in the spring
actually fall or late summer of 2006
Josh Birnbaum who is the head ABS trader
at goldman sachs was that paulson and
company and he was over there invited
over by john paulson after he had
established this bet is a short against
these toxic mortgages toxic mortgage
product and Birnbaum was bullish and
Paulson invited him over there and he
gets a lot of credit and I think there's
a real lesson there that Paulson invited
groups of analysts many of whom are
bullish over to the firm to challenge
their thesis and Birnbaum sat across and
I've got seen in my book he sits across
from the experts at Paulson and he's and
he's the number one guy in the street
and he knows it's not better than
Paulson again more possum was a merger
armed for many years and he kind of was
learning about this stuff and Birnbaum
says whatever you're selling I'm gonna
buy and the guys have possible taken
aback they weren't really sure what he
was trying to what message he was
sending was he trying to help them
because he was he traded with them maybe
he was trying to help them out or was he
trying to fake them out a little bit
maybe he was sick of taking other side
of their positions because they kept
shorting and shorting and shorting and
maybe he was holding too much of it and
he was trying to tell them hey stop it
so much he's trying to fake them but
they weren't really sure all they knew
was that the top guy in the business was
telling them was warning them and yet
they kept with their trade and again
that says to me yeah Paulson gets a lot
of credit but goldman sachs was a little
like this too and to their credit they
turned on a dime and they realized in
late oh six and early oh seven how
dangerous some of this mortgage product
was that was sitting out in their books
and they turned around and not only shed
some of it but they started shorting it
and to me that's kind of a mark of a
great investor in great firm so they got
a lot of credit but going you know back
to my earlier theme the experts really
didn't see this coming and part of it is
that they're too caught up in their own
worlds and you know when it comes to the
experts who are investors who should
have seen this coming the mortgage
experts when they were guys who dealt
with mortgage product day in and day out
for years years and years this is what
they did and yet this merger RBI this
john paulson was the one who realized
how toxic it was i mean why was that a
part of it what is because they it's all
relative value on wall street and you
don't really make home runs too often so
a lot in this world and sort of the
lorentz back kind of bond world
so it was all sort of what pool of
mortgages looks better than the next so
I'm going to buy this one I'm not going
to buy that one maybe I'll buy this one
I'll short this one if I can
it's all relative value normally took us
to step back and and that speaks to kind
of a problem on Wall Street and if you
think about it the people that rise to
the top at the firms are you given that
play by the rules are the people that
kind of the are really good in the
institution's the Geithner's and the the
Bernanke's and the Hank Paulson Hank
false ran goldman sachs Moynihan back
America there are people that really
could within these firms but these firms
don't usually have people sitting around
thinking about the details the bad
things what bad can happen or taking it
just a step back I mean Chuck Prince is
famous for saying we have to keep
dancing until the music's over and that
was sort of the attitude that still is
sort of the attitude on Wall Street
where yeah maybe I'm a little worried
about this product that I've got on my
books or that I'm selling to investors
but if I don't sell it if I don't put on
my books then someone else will and I'm
going to learn I'm going to lose maybe
and if you sense earnings per share etc
and that's a real problem I'm also we
don't really have the the people that
think a little differently we don't have
enough of these people and part of the
issue is the hedge fund worlds because
it pays so well and it draws out town
but this is just a draw town the people
that the my hands in the the Bernanke's
all those kind of people that play by
the rules this is smart is the hedge
fund guys but the edge amount of people
are very entrepreneurial it's one reason
I enjoy writing about them they think a
little bit outside the box again no
smart around think you're sharp
but that smarter than the people are
worth in the firm's but it's sort of a
self-selecting group that people that
take the risk and go join a hedge fund
or go try to run a hedge fund they don't
like working for the people often and
they think about what that can happen
often they're a little more skeptical i
i've found and unfortunately they get
drawn out of these firms and what's left
are really smart people that are worried
about the corns quarter too often it
Goldman Sachs does really well and I
think part of the reason is because they
keep a relationship people know by
definition more entrepreneurial people I
think who maybe want to start a hedge
fund they know that half of exaggerated
funds are started by X Goldman Sachs
guys so maybe by definition against a
self-selecting group the entrepreneurial
wants to go to Goldman and then Goldman
to their credit they keep in touch with
a lot of the X Goldman people so if
you're a risk manager at Goldman Sachs I
think it's easier to make a few calls
and see what the real risks are out
there as opposed to maybe another firm
and maybe that's some kind of lessons
that some other firms can learn by but
there's the sense that I had that each
of these firms became more leveraged and
didn't realize the overall scope of the
risk and instead kind of saw the subsets
in their own worlds and no one kind of
was able to take a step back the other
points is unfortunately or fortunately
is that you make so much money on Wall
Street that there aren't many people
with great experienced institutional
experience there are many people that
remember ldcm who worked on Wall Street
and the the implosion of long term
capital management in 1998 in any other
industry the people that do really well
usually stick around and got they don't
make so much that they can retire but
these guys can retire after you know 10
15 years if you're really good so the
really good ones often left either start
a hedge fund or to retire live in some
islands and unfortunately the ones that
were left with often younger and they
hadn't remembered that in the early 90s
how the market actually did have some
problems against I mean if you live in
Boston you remember that in from
California it wasn't on a national scale
but clearly there was some history and
some of the older people actually
remembered that I mean again John
Paulson was approaching 50 years old as
was Apollo Pellegrini Jeffrey green that
playboy investor out in California Hugh
made over a billion dollars on this
trade he was approaching 50 so there's
some something to be said for having
that experience and or these having
someone are in the firm with some of
that experience and too often some of
the firm's I think on the street don't
have those kind of people with the exact
kind of expiry
the other issues is that lot of things
move incrementally and you have to have
patience and that's not exactly a virtue
that's rewarded at many firms on the
street again there's a lot of
competition and you know if things
change slowly and it really did it took
years I mean it's a myth that people
weren't bearish on housing and weren't
worried about housing my brother
Ezra has written about some of those
kind of issues and it's documented that
there were all kinds of people who who
bet against housing in 2003 in 2004 and
May got burnt and some who could hold on
ended up doing really well and making a
lot of money but it's hard to when we're
we're in a world where it's much easier
to compare it to be compared and compare
yourself against others or your other
managers or other investment firms and
people used to be maybe on a quarterly
basis or on a yearly basis not daily
people look at these screens they know
what they're doing then other P&L the
profit and loss every minute but they
also know they have a sense for their
competitors you'd be surprised I mean I
talk to these guys all day long and
people often kind of criticize me a
criticize the multi journal for negative
you always write negative stories about
about hedge funds and in the industry
and the stories come from people in the
industry because they all hear what each
other are doing and they're the first
ones to kind of call up and tell me
who's blowing up and doing poorly and
that's because they're very focused on
each other they're invoke Asst
on their own returns and doing well for
their investors but they're very focused
on their our competitors and their
rivals it's a fascinating thing where
they're very worth is often determined
by that computer screen and the P&L for
that day and you could have done really
well the year before and as you probably
you know these guys as well as I do and
or you have a career of making so much
what you don't have to work it doesn't
work a lot of these guys I talked to
don't have to work they really don't and
they probably be you know curing cancer
but they're not instead they're really
focused on this trade this trade and
this year in this corner and today and
trying to beat the next guy and half of
them you know our former athletes or
wannabe or they've got that adrenaline
that's the
and that makes them happy and there's a
argument isn't probably other discussion
that you know for the free flow of
capital and allocation of capital that's
could be a good thing we probably too
many of these guys we clearly have too
many of these guys focused on these kind
of trades but we do need sharp people
allocating capital the way where it
should be
so these people are very focused on
themselves and on their competitors and
these firms were very very focused on
their competitors and that cost them I
think in the end and they saw these
incremental changes but they didn't take
a step back and kind of see what could
happen what kind of the tail might be
the other really fascinating thing I
found in my research for this book is
one of the reasons why people didn't do
this trade I'll explain in a second is
that it costs money and what I mean by
that is I guess I'll explain it now
basically the subprime trade is the one
that John Paulson and the other
investors that I focus on is basically
it was here I'll kind of take you to
John Paulson and here he was in 2005 or
so and he has got these vague worries
about housing he he's not a housing guy
he'd bought a house or two and sold a
serger but he's not housing guy and he's
looking for protection on his overall
portfolio but puts on the sp500 which
would protect downside if the stock
market fell they were expensive at a
time so he was just looking for some
other way to hedge himself and
Pellegrini
again his right-hand man native of Italy
and he had been just at the firm for
about half a year so he said well John
you might want to think about these
credit default swaps and credit fault
swaps sound complicated but they're not
really they're just basically a
derivative it's a way to kind of ensure
yourself it's insurance contracts on you
can do it on anything on any kind of
debt basically and it ensures debt so if
debt defaults if you buy that debt and
but and you've got the ins a false but
you've got this insurance that's credit
default swap insurance then you're
protected so Pellegrini said to Paulson
wait you know boss you should look at
this credit default swap stuff it
protects your downside and just like any
insurance contract your downside is
protected because you pay a certain
amount for a protect
just like any insurance premium you pay
an annual kind of fee and you're
protected
so Paulson's like wow i never knew much
about this I may be vaguely heard about
this credit default swap derivative
instrument and he threw himself into it
and learning about it and to me that's
one of the most impressive things about
those that did this trade I mean again
if you think about it many of these
investors were approaching 50 and they'd
already done really well and credit
default swaps are complicated or they
can't they can't be very complicated and
their derivatives and Warren Buffett is
warned about derivatives weapons of mass
destruction and I talked to I crisscross
the country talking to comma top
investors but why didn't do this trade
Bill Gross I mean Bill Gross is the bond
King out in California and he said well
you know derivatives aren't really what
I do and yeah I could do it Gregg but my
investors don't really want me to do so
much of it and it's true a lot of
investors a little wary of credit
default swaps these derivative
investments and they eventually helped
lead to the downfall of AIG so there's
reason potentially to to be wary of them
but john paulson threw himself into
learning about them and learning the ins
it out to them and Pellegrini as well
and the thing about credit fault swaps
is they cost money as I said they're
like an insurance contract and they were
dirt cheap in 2005 they were dirt cheap
and 2006 also and yet no one else is
really behind too much than john paulson
just came from this other world here is
this merger ARB he has vague worries
about housing and Pellegrini tells him
about the spreads fall shop and he's
like wait a second my downside is like
7% or so and my upside is hundreds of
percent a year that's how they worked
out the trade why isn't everybody doing
this trade and sort of question why I
kept asking and unfortunately the one of
the reasons is negative carry negative
carry is sort of sounds complicated
again but basically just means you're
paying out at the beginning of the year
the everyone starts fresh and again
everyone's focused on themselves and on
their competitors and to pay out to buy
this insurance well I don't want to be
behind my competitor yeah we'll be
behind him by more than like half a
percentage point if I even buy a lot of
this credit default swap but no one
really wanted to buy
percentage point behind their competitor
it's a fascinating thing to me because
you know the outsider wood is backed up
the truck and bought as much of this
stuff as possible which is what John
Paulson did and it helped being an
outsider which is kind of one of the
themes of the book but people on the
inside who get judged day to day and are
worried about being up 7% for the year
when their big competitor is up 7 half
percent a year they're not buying this
stuff but a lot of people said Oh crikey
I understood the trade I got on it but
negative carry and that was sort of
their justification and I may be in that
world that's you don't want to you'd
rather risk being it's actually worse
for a lot of these people unfortunately
it's actually worse being behind a half
percentage point or for a full
percentage point some of your rivals
than it is missing out the trade of a
lifetime if it means that everybody else
missed that out missed out on the trade
saying that's what happened most people
miss this trade so the guy that passed
on the trade is still got his job and
he's still making a few million a year
and yeah cast on the trade Greg but hey
look at me now doing pretty well so
unfortunately that's sort of you you're
not rewarded for sake taking these I
guess career risk is really what it is
and it's funny the guy that takes the
most risk in my book is a guy named is
this guy Greg Lippmann because Greg
Lippmann was within a bank who's working
at Deutsche Bank and people thought he
was crazy people made fun of him they
teased him they called him a fool
because he was worried about housing and
he was buying this credit default swaps
and people are working with him his
senior people his bosses they all kind
of said well yeah you can do a little
bit of the stuff Greg but I check back
with us daily and we want to hear about
this trade and they'll take out in too
much risk and he ends it up and I won't
again too much of dough but he ended up
doing some things just to make money to
keep his bosses happy so he could keep
this trade on but if this trade hadn't
worked he would be known as the foo bet
against housing Oh Greg didn't know you
know the housing never goes down on a
national basis don't you know that the
Fed can always cut rates great don't you
know that you're taking real career risk
and he really did and yet he stuck to
his guns and again if he hadn't done
this trade
still be making a few million a year
because everybody else missed the trade
big deal and housing collapsed all
perfect storm perfect storm we all write
about a perfect storm was a perfect
storm it was just people made mistakes
and didn't see this thing coming but oh
yeah perfect storm was you know come up
the people that had blew it kalmyk came
up with this kind of explanation perfect
storm but so great let me could have
said oh yeah oh yeah I missed the
trayvis oh did everybody else and you
know you know analysts are all our
analysts said you know don't worry well
some of them we're actually skeptical a
judge but many weren't so he takes real
career risk and he takes the biggest
risk to me of anybody in this
foreignness that I write about largely
because he had more downside when it
comes to the stuff he was very making a
good living and yet he did the risk the
trade anyway excuse me
so those are the people that should have
done it and again um I guess one of the
things the things I have come to the
conclusion I've come to is that Wall
Street talks a big game about being
contrarian now being contrarian investor
their books written and they're not
contrarian at all they're they're all
more than ever people jump on trades and
that's why I think we're actually in the
age of bubbles where the hot trade is
communicated much more easily than ever
before and sort of maybe a separate
topic but I do think we're in this
period where I mean as an academic you
would think that markets should be
coming should be becoming more efficient
over time right not more inefficient
you've got more information out there
that more people going playing playing
playing investing I should say and yeah
slip of the tongue
and and and and you would think things
should be becoming more efficient and
should have fewer bubbles not more
bubbles over time and yet and Jeremy
Grantham has documented everything he's
got he counts maybe 26 or so financial
bubbles in the past century if you just
think the last few years we've had
obviously the housing bubble energy
prices oil prices they shot up to 140 a
barrel down to 40 50 back up to 70 Asian
markets Asian currencies in 1997 or so
and the tech bubble obviously was a was
a huge bubble it's my view that it's
easier than ever for people to jump on
trades it used to be the case that if
I'm a commodity expert I don't do
anything about stocks what do I know
from stocks I'm just doing commodities
Obama stock I out do commodities if they
need a/c down to trade and how do I do
it nowadays they're ETFs and there are
credit fall swaps there are other kinds
of derivative ways to to express a trade
and to me it's leading to just more of
these bubbles we're going to have more
of them and people piling on the trade
and it's troublesome it's it's worrisome
and you wonder kind of where we are now
maybe China and maybe I you know some
Brazil was up about 100 percent last
year and people already talking about
Canadian real estate as a bubble I'm not
saying it is but I do think that we're
kind of at the point where there may be
too many of these bubbles and it's
costly and again Wall Street is not as
contrarian as that think so it jumps on
these bubbles largely because they're
worried about what the competitors are
doing and they don't want to be left out
I mean I've been writing a lot about the
pigs trade it's called the pigs trade
now actually I think we outlawed that
The Wall Street Journal I apologize um
Portugal Italy Ireland Greece and Spain
so it's betting against those countries
bidding against the debt of those
countries and all kinds of investors are
doing it it's not just your sovereign
debt experts your bond experts people
that are experts and kind of
international fairs or anything like
that people who never knew anything
about these countries I'm not sure I
assume that can find on the map I hope
so they're piling on this trade and I'm
not saying it's a bad thing it's just
interesting dynamic and you're going to
get more of these and it's hard to be a
contrarian on the streets harder than
ever I would think so again so why was
it these investors that I write about
why was it John Paulson and Paula
Pellegrini Jeffrey Green Michael burry
Gregg Lippmann so there's there again
there's a myth out there that everybody
drank the kool-aid and everybody
believed in housing between my brother
counts these data between 2000 and 2003
there were about 1400 mentions of the
phrase housing bubble in articles and US
public
Asians over the next three years there
were 5500 mentions of the phrase and
there were big stories and prominent
stories and big newspapers and other
places so it wasn't the case that my
investors the ones I write about were
the only ones who were skeptical there a
lot of people skeptical so why was it
they that came up with one of the
reasons is they were a little some of
them were a little late to the game and
that can help so you know good fortune
here is important as well so there were
investors who put on this trade who
bought credit default swaps this
insurance on subprime mortgages then
they bought it in 2003 2004 and nothing
happened and their bosses got upset and
they took the trade off or they took the
trade off themselves and their investors
got upset and their clients weren't
thrilled with that they were losing
money and other people bet against home
builders or try to come up with another
way to bet against housing and they
weren't there weren't a lot of great
ways there were if you bet against let's
say a home builder it didn't really work
for a long time and then even if you
were convinced that eventually would
work there's a lot consolidation in that
industry and maybe the one that you bet
against would actually end up doing
pretty well and there's that danger and
a lot of times it hurt people so there
were a lot of ways to kind of get
cautious about housing you could you
know move the missus and the kids out of
the house and and rent that's hard you
know they got friends and you know a lot
of stuff in the house it's not easy to
do
there weren't many ways to do it and
those that we're worried and figured
these credit default swaps out early it
took actually a while for them to be
really great trading mechanisms and it
is one thesis that it took and it took
till 2005 in early 2006 for there to be
a really great way to bet against
housing bet against subprime mortgages
and that was these credit default swaps
when they introduced synthetic ones
where you can bet against kind of a pool
you don't have to own the pool and
basically just kind of buy some
insurance and then there's a B X index
which tracks subprime mortgages so that
was all introduced kind of oh five and
oh six and then maybe it's not a
coincidence that perhaps that's when
things started
floating but it really wasn't easy to
bet against housing and it was it was a
better to be late than to be early on
this trade and that's what John Paulson
some of these people had going for them
in that they got nervous about housing
in 2005 and then 2006 is when things
started flattening out and then early
2007 is when there was the implosion and
it all kind of fell apart the housing
markets so it helped being or being late
and having some good fortune there and
also helped ignoring the experts I mean
as I said John Paulson to his credit
invited all kinds of analysts top guys
into his firm and to challenge their
thesis and to their credit they they
stuck with the thesis and they held on
to it and I give them more credit for
that than I do just from kind of putting
on the trade and being early holding
onto your conviction and it's a
remarkable temperament that allows
yourself to do that you have to be
really self confident and ignore
everybody else and what happened was
Paula greenie he came up with this chart
and it showed housing prices on a
national basis over the past I think was
maybe 75 to 80 years or so and it
basically was right in front of them it
was just clear kind of things were kind
of slowly slowly slowly growing and boom
they shot up and they figured out Wow
and Pellegrini came to Paulson he's like
boss check this out and pasta-like sat
back in his chair literally and he's
like wow look at this data it's right
here it's clear we start betting against
housing and that's why they held on to
it now the irony here is that um there
were the first people to come up with
this data a Robert Shiller had already
published it maybe a year earlier but
Pellegrini came up with it himself and
he became convinced of it as did Paulson
and they held on to their conviction and
that's pretty impressive because again
it's much it's hard when you have all
the experts telling you one thing and
your clients were nervous I mean they're
a lot of investors their own clients who
didn't really believe in the trade some
did and some realize that it was very
little downside and it was huge upside
but hey here's a stock guy merger our
guy John Paulson
what's he buying all the subprime
protection for and that's why Paulson
smart in that he had a lot of it in his
own funds but he said you know if I'm
really gonna make a big huge bet here
I've got to really set up a new fund
just dedicated to this trade what a one
trade fund now a lot of people in Wall
Street are doing that a Bill Ackman did
one for target and these others but at
the time there weren't that many people
it was seen as you know supposed to you
need some precipitation how do you have
one trade in a fund and when he first
started raising money john paulson had
real difficulty he only raised 147
million dollars epic echo in early 2006
for this dedicated funds he was rejected
time after time he went into harvard and
they said that we don't see it we don't
get it other ways to express this trade
and they didn't do the trade didn't do
this trade but they they thought they
had a better way to do it
maybe he got rejected there he got
rejected a lot of different places and
the experts all told them you know again
housing doesn't fall on a national basis
the Fed could always step in how you
didn't get out of your trade and things
like that and impulsing just stuck to
his guns and that kind of conviction to
me is pretty impressive and it as is I'm
really impressed by how he held on to
the trade and in I'm going to tell you
in 2007 in February 2007 they made 66%
in a single month now I just give you
come from context they had never really
made more than a few percentage points
in a single month they made 66 percent
in one month they were making more they
made more in one morning then George
Soros made betting against the British
Pound and George Soros made about a
billion dollars betting against British
pounds for his hedge fund only and
Paulson was making billions and he's
been Pellegrini I'd never really been
paid much before so he comes to his boss
and he says hey we should be taking some
of this trade off right and Paulson said
no well look at the data don't forget
the data Paul don't forget the data and
it helped it Paulson already was wealthy
so he didn't need to take his profits
like other people did would have been
tempted to he held on to his he stayed
with his conviction again it's either up
66% in a month and their own investors
called up and they said you mean six
point six percent is a typo here guys
right and and they said no 66% and some
of them say take the trade off some sort
of encourage them to some of them said
well move me to another fun
doesn't have as much exposure to these
these subprime CBS credit fall swaps
which is what the trade was and Paulson
did and he didn't kind of break stride
he held on to this trade and again that
kind of conviction and to me is pretty
impressive and that to me he gets all
kinds of credit for that the other
lesson or the other kind of theme that
I've learned from from Paulson and his
trade and I've learned from sort of some
other people that have done really well
and then I've written about is the idea
and Buffett answers have both gotten
into this before it's the idea of going
for the jugular and when you see an
opportunity you're many it's like it in
sports too many of my metaphors in my
book are sports and I apologize for that
but it's it's very much like sports
where in in every act that they say you
have one or two pitches to hit you know
some are going to be bad pitches some
are just pictures you can't really
handle but you're going to get one or
two and those are ones you've really got
pounce on it you've got to hit out of
the ballpark and it's funny talking to
these investors they all kind of say the
same thing that Paulson and new Soros
and Buffett and temper they say you're
not going to have too many these
opportunities but when you've got them
you got a go for him you don't have too
many and that's sort of where policy
gets a lot of credit he saw this huge
opportunity and he jumped on it and he
backed up the truck and he ignored
everybody else and it's sort of a cliche
you know be confident yourself but
they've got this remarkable ability and
it's almost these guys Paulson and
others they've got this ability to kind
of turn on a dime and Paulson for
example so in interim in 2007 the firm
made fifteen billion dollars betting
against housing and betting against
subprime mortgages again by far the
greatest trade in financial history
Soros had made a billion dollars bidding
against British Pound in 1992 so he
makes fifteen billion dollars in 2007
and then in 2008 he made another five
billion dollars transforming the trade
and this where he gets a lot of credit
as well in my book my eyes my book no
pun intended
shifting the trade from one against
housing to one against financial firms
because he saw where the dominoes were
going to fall he said wait hold on a
second okay so housing is falling apart
subprime is melting down well who's
holding this stuff and they did the
research and they realize
look at Marilyn look at city and these
these firms bear and Lehman and they
started buying credit vault swaps not on
the mortgages which they had been doing
but on the firm's themselves and they
made another five billion dollars doing
that in 2008 but then in early 2009 he
doesn't just take the trades off he
starts going long he started buying the
very banks that he had bet against and
it's really a remarkable I would say
impressive it is impressive as an
investor and I see it all the time with
the best investors they've got this
almost impersonal kind of way of looking
at their portfolio they don't fall in
love with their investments which is
what the average investor often does
someone told me that you don't want to
be married to these kinds of people they
can really they can kind of separate and
not get tied up emotionally it's not to
say John Paul's and you know want to be
married too it's probably good person to
be there i - it's good it's a good
father and a good husband I'm told but
you know but you don't fall in love with
the portfolio and it doesn't necessarily
make for someone you would necessarily
be friends with but it's a great
investing trait not to be so emotionally
involved and invested as it were in your
portfolio so going for the jugular and
not not kind of falling in love with
your investment those are sort of some
of the themes that I kind of picked up
from from these investors and been
impressive to me I was just going to
fund a Segway a little bit - why what
what these kind of investors are doing
now and the biggest trade that I've been
following have been driven to actually
one is the gold trade so John Paulson in
late 2008 as things were melting down
and we were throwing money at all the
problems out there as a government he
started taking a look at gold because he
was worried about the money supply
leading to inflation and gold is a great
way to hedge historically it's been a
way to hedge inflation there been other
top investors were buying gold as well
it's a fascinating investment because
it's very different from the housing bed
because there's a much more downside I
mean we don't really know what gold is
worth what's gold worth it's about 1,100
today is that cheap is that expensive I
don't really know no you can't deceive
fit as you guys maybe
to do you can't dividend model it
doesn't pay a dividends what's gold
worth and why do we even like gold I
mean David Einhorn know one of the top
investors he's got a vault in Queens
somewhere filled with gold and he
doesn't own it because his wife Cheryl
is a big fan of gold or anything he
likes gold because he thinks the next
guy is going to like it even more so you
know that sounds like a greater
full-color trade and yet historically
for thousands of years gold has held up
as and been an alternative to to paper
currency so yeah I get it if you're
basing your paper currency Gold's not a
bad place to be
I just find it to be a fascinating
investment and it could double in price
and it could be cut in half and some of
the very investors that I'm running
about who bet against housing and
shifted to do that including John
Paulson others are betting against these
these countries like Greece and some of
the others and they've done really well
with it and it's an interesting trade
it's not clear how are you going to make
money on the other side of things really
implode who's on the other side it's a
little bit like the CVS tray you have to
worry about who's being who's on the
other side of these trades what a lot of
these people really are betting on is
just that either either the Euro
implodes and collapses or just that
yields a lot of these bonds the debt the
rate that a lot of the countries are
paying is just going to have to go
higher as as in continue go higher as
people just kind of worried about these
debts and then the real homerun trade is
Japan some of the investors are betting
against interest rates in Japan which
have been low forever they're about 1.3
percent 10-year japanese bonds 1.3
percent say i'm in above 2 percent in
years and yet and that's why it's really
cheap to bet against it's by credit
default swaps or do other kind of
foreign currency kind of moves that are
ineffective debt that if the rates go a
little bit higher then japan is going to
have trouble paying its debt and the
exam to restructure doesn't have to go
much higher they argue before they the
interest costs get really high and then
you have a little trouble so a lot of
these people are betting against japan
and we'll see how that does so those are
kind of the big kind of trades i'm
working on right now and i invite any
and all questions about anything about
but the book the greatest trade ever or
anything else I'm writing about right
now
Gregg Gregg I think I get the privilege
of the first question okay we all we
only have talker one there I find it
interesting that both the greatest great
ever and the second greatest trade ever
I saw of shorting the pound we're short
uh uh do you think that that there are
more great traits among short span
that's interesting um they tend to be
more asymmetrical and that's what these
guys looked for so the crowd generally
does well the herd as it were bending on
things go higher and things generally
have gone higher and things improved
over time so it's the the outlier kind
of trade is often the short trade it's
not always the winning one but yeah that
often is Gregory Zuckerman is a senior
writer at The Wall Street Journal and
writes the papers heard on the street
column